you know my first time in my life having
to be in a criminal court because I'm a
law-abiding citizen this was my first
one
um being labeled as a criminal for
exercising my freedom of speech it is a
made-up term I do believe that it is a
word an expression that has a mission
behind it it seems to be attacking
psychologists and professionals but it's
also targeting churches and Faith
communities so I I don't like it for
that reason but I can tell you how the
Maltese law defines conversion practices
thank you
hi guys Wayne Blakely from know his love
Ministries a guest again happy to be
here with LED live also as a guest is
Daniel both of us have left the LGBT
culture if you didn't see the previous
program this is a program today with
Matthew greck from Malta it's going to
be very interesting program you probably
recognize the name because he's been in
the news all the way all around the
world as it relates to Christianity and
the LGBT plus culture so I want to
welcome our Our Guest Matthew greck from
Malta welcome everyone thank you for
having me
Matthew uh thank you for your testimony
that you shared in the previous program
and you have just been sharing your
testimony since you left the LGBT
culture for you know a few years now but
something Dynamic happened tell me what
happened
[Music]
yes
um so
uh it was in April 2022 that I was
invited to
share my story and my views on
homosexuality and transgenderism
um
on a liberal a small liberal emerging
platform in Malta
called PM news Malta
and um these hosts uh knew that I had a
of course a Biblical approach to sex and
marriage and um they also had questions
about so-called conversion therapy since
we are here in Malta and the context of
a ban on so-called conversion practices
so I guess they wanted to understand the
subject better and they had valid
questions they they are for freedom of
speech so they're not afraid to to
challenge ideas you know so they have me
on and we have this really good
discussion that is practical that is
spiritual that is scientific
and it goes on for like two hours I
think and um
and it you know it gets
small traction because it's a small
platform but yet
um the LGBT Lobby
found out about it because actually they
were approached uh I think the motor gay
rights movement was approached to speak
on the same program and they refused to
debate with us
and my presence so I guess that's how
they were able to monitor this and know
about it
and um you know it was fine for a few
days until
I received a phone call from a
policewoman uh telling me hey you know
you were on this program and you and you
talked about this and that and uh there
are allegations against you and against
the hosts uh that you uh guys were
advertising so-called conversion
practices she's like we don't wouldn't
really know about this law before but it
is a thing and we need you to come to
the police station and answer
um and so we had to respond and I chose
to be accompanied by my lawyer
and we show up and we exercise our
rights to be silent we're given the
names of and the ID card numbers of the
people who reported us to the police
it's been an article released yesterday
that basically
identifies who these three people are on
Morty's media because now it's like this
widespread uh news in Malta and anyway
one of them is a top EU
Maltese person who was uh involved with
the European Minister for equality who
was also a Maltese woman herself I know
mortar somehow has a lot of influence in
the EU at the moment also because the
president of the European Parliament is
Maltese herself it's another woman it's
Roberta metzola so um
there's something that is working here
and and so one of Silvana juice is one
of the people who who is behind a lot of
LGBT policies on a transnational level
and on a global scale and so he reported
me to the police with two other folks
who are actually involved with or have
been evolved in the past with the malta
gay rights movement
and the Maltese government itself so
it's like this is
this screaming Maltese government it's
screaming EU and it's screaming the
malta gay rights movement working
together and you know they were making
the allegations that we broke chapter
five six seven and Maltese law which
says you cannot advertise so-called
conversion practices we're told okay you
have every right to be silent and not to
answer any questions so we're not gonna
bother asking you anything you know but
they said
the Police Inspector might call you for
an interview
we waited for a few days
and
then were notified that the police did
not the Police Inspector did not bother
interviewing us but they pressed charges
they went ahead and um at the time they
told us that we have our first we were
to have our first hearing uh in February
last month which already happened now so
you know my first time in my life having
to be in a criminal court because I'm a
law-abiding citizen I never I had to
face a court a case in my life and this
was my first one
um being labeled as a criminal for
exercising my freedom of speech
practically so so Matthew for for the
sake of our viewers and for anybody
who's heard this term before tell me
what is the definition of conversion
therapy that's an important question
because I I always like to say
you know that different people
uh Define conversion therapy differently
it is a made-up term you know and
I I I do believe that it is a word an
expression that has a mission behind it
so I don't like to use it myself because
I don't like the mission that's behind
it one might say well what's the mission
you know conversion has to do with uh
religion and faith and uh and therapy
seems to relate to psychology and and
and everything and so it seems to be
attacking psychologists and
professionals but it's also targeting
churches and Faith communities so I I
don't like it for that reason but I can
tell you how the Maltese law defines
conversion practices because it says it
refers to any treatment practice or
sustained efforts that aims to change
repress and or eliminate a person's
sexual orientation gender identity
or and gender expression
and then the mortise law tells you what
conversion practices does not include
but that's maybe for another time later
on during this interview but that's how
it is defined in the law I think it's
important to stick to to the way uh this
term is defined in the law itself
because people will will say all sorts
of things so
my mind is just kind of turning right
now and
um
I'm wondering is is I mean it sounds
like the law is written
for both ways so in other words if I
were to flip that on its head and then
there were activists from the LGBT plus
Community who wanted me to change
that would be okay that be conversion
therapy yeah but you're converting to
the right position I'm just arguing on
the technicality of the law the
stupidity of this just immediately emits
and yet nobody in the in LGBT rights
which is all around the world all
through government and all through the
culture itself can see how the freedoms
only go one way
and it's just absolutely mind-boggling
you had to have been sitting there in
the in the at the at the police station
going I did what you know because
you know to to share your testimony and
then be arrested for it is just
downright insane but that's what's
beginning to happen to people today and
so it's what you ask as a heterosexual
to me is what all heterosexuals should
be saying well how come the The
Narrative is only going One Direction
wouldn't it be just the same if you were
approached and said you know you can't
um you know that you you need to become
um gay which you know a lot of LGBT
people are thinking today you know I can
tell all the stories of people I'm just
thinking about the educational work
that's done in schools yes these days I
mean in the public schools at least in
the United States there is an effort to
bring uh in a more expansive education
into the classroom you know as young as
you know third grade first grade
yeah and and to me that seems like a
sustained effort to change one's sexual
orientation orientation and identity I'm
just thinking that sounds logically like
this same thing and so why
and maybe you've observed it's the same
thing in Malta I don't know what they're
doing in the in the Educational
Department for children but if they are
that seems like is it a two-way street
or not right I was thinking the same
thing so we're talking about a TV show
is is telling a testimony but yet all
these children's programmings you got
Arthur and Sesame Street and Blue's
Clues saying hey there's 80 genders and
all this stuff isn't that conversion
therapy literally I mean it seems like
it mm-hmm
in the younger generation we see that
studies have been showing that the LGBT
um ideology or sexual orientation people
that identify with a different gender is
rising and the young people yeah and the
younger generation so it just seems like
all these things are just kind of
pushing this mentality and
um just to keep it brief like I've had
clients where I because I also do
practice as a therapist as my profession
and I have seen some clients who aren't
necessarily
um
truly gender confused about their gender
as much as they're confused because
they're being told that this is another
option for you and and Adolescence that
development is typical for people to
explore who they are in their identity
that is a normal part of development and
with this thing Rising is causing more
confusion and as Christians who believe
in a God that came to save us from sin
we know that within that context that is
really where true freedom is and these
laws are going against our basic
religious freedom as well amen
and you know they also the biology shows
that the settling in as it relates to
you know sexual orientation and those
kinds of things that are happening in
our mind really don't solidify until
we're like you know 25 years old yeah so
question for you Matthew and because
you're in the sounds like in the middle
of the legal heat of all this uh to your
knowledge not that you're a lawyer
necessarily but to your knowledge is the
law written as a one-way Street or is
there the technicality that this is a
two-way street by the way the law is
written and it can apply both ways I
think that uh
people need to uh understand the subject
and
the thing is the law itself is uh
dogmatic about it it is ideological
because it starts by saying that this
law is to affirm that all persons have a
sexual orientation a gender identity and
a gender expression and and that no
particular combination of these three
characteristics constitutes a disorder a
disease an illness deficiency etc etc
and and and to prohibit conversion
practices as a deceptive and harmful Act
or intervention against a person's
sexual orientation gender identity or
gender expression so it's basically
telling you how you should be thinking
about sexuality and it's it's it's
religious in itself you know it's saying
well if you try to change you're
deceiving yourself and you're harmful
you're harming yourself and we're saying
who are you as they go as the government
to tell me that I'm deceiving myself or
harming myself if I wanna seek to change
any of these characteristics and what is
that going to change for you as a
government anyway why are you intruding
in people's personal choices it's
absolutely bizarre uh it screams
communism and it should have no place
and no state in America and certainly No
Other Nation
um and so
if we know how they think if we know
their arguments and are able to bring
them down we can use the law against
them similarly similarly to the way
David used Goliath's swords to kill us
what is aggravating about this is is to
me the LGBT community who has screamed
freedom
are now holding their own hostage so if
you have an LGBT person who says well I
tried that but I don't care to live like
this anymore I want to leave this
they're saying no you can't live you
have to live this way you you can't
there's no way out um we're not going to
allow you to leave and Beyond Freedom
there's also love right the love to let
someone choose
right despite what you despite agreeing
with their choice or not you know so you
have again the LGBT community who's
saying that the church and Christianity
is hateful is is Distributing hate
towards
the church therefore doing the very same
thing that they're accusing that is
being that they think that is being done
towards them
so are you uh it sounds like there's a
very real possibility if you're in the
middle of a legal battle what does that
mean for you personally is there a a
possibility that you may wind up in jail
or prison uh yeah good question so uh
the law says that
um well it's worth mentioning what it
what the law says is actually unlawful
so when you actually read the law you
understand first of all this is just
like a three-page document a three-page
document so it's not a long uh law to
read so anybody can read through it it's
chapter five six seven Maltese law but
it does say it does distinguish between
lawful conversion practices and unlawful
conversion practices which is a
contradiction
um because first it says conversion
practices are harmful but then it says
but these are lawful and these are not
so it's just all over the place in my
personal opinion and observation but it
says it shall be unlawful for any person
to perform conversion practices on a
vulnerable person or perform involuntary
and or forced conversion practices on a
person
or advertise conversion practices
it's so inclusive and so it it seems to
be coming against uh performing such
practices on vulnerable people uh which
would be like minors anyway vulnerable
is defined uh in the law and then uh it
seems to be coming against scenarios
where people are forced into change and
we're asking who's doing that in Malta
for God's sake I mean who is practicing
and forcing people to change nobody is
doing that this is
this is like introducing a law against
something that nobody is doing anyway
so Matthew it I'm thinking that the
conversion therapy ban took place in
Malta in 2016. there's many bands all
around the world but it sounds to me
that they've been waiting since 2016 to
find a scapegoat and they finally found
one
that's so true because Malta was the
first country in the EU to introduce
such a Ben and um I think Malta seems to
have somehow a forerunner kind of
pioneering uh anointing which which the
enemy is using uh against Malta but we
want
it's to be used for God's glory not for
the enemy's use so unfortunately right
now if it feels like the the counterfeit
is happening but we're believing that
Malta will will will uh be known for
praise and worship and the Miracles of
God and not not the normalization of of
perversion uh you know unfortunately but
yes it has been uh targeted in fact
Malta is number one on elga's Rainbow
index so Elga Europe is this
transnational organization that is
promoting everything LGBT across Europe
and uh and Malta is right there number
one and it's trying to I think conform
to to be 100 compliant and now this year
for instance in Malta this Euro pride is
is happening they're bringing Pride on a
European scale into Malta and so there
is a fierce uh spiritual battle uh over
our Island uh because of this
um and and God's people are are applying
resistance and and and coming up with
ideas to to come against this demonic
spirit in this island but uh yeah it
continues to be targeted because people
be like wait wait wait a minute you know
if a small island like Malta is is
already so much ahead of other nations
how much more should the bigger Nations
follow you know and it's this idea that
oh look you know we're a small island
but we're number one top of the list I
think it's time for God's people to have
their own lists of like Holiness and
righteousness and say look in Europe
This is the most Godly nation and this
is the least coordination on God's index
you know so it sounds like that Malta is
is ramping up and all of Europe well I'm
sure they know it's beyond Europe
because it's around the world that are
watching and so you know your um what's
the word I want the the penalties in
Malta uh praise the Lord are a little
less than what they are in some of the
other countries where this is Criminal
so in Malta you if convicted would serve
five months in prison and up to five
thousand dollar euros and I'm perplexed
as to you know what the situation is and
if you could tell me
what's what's happening to you now how
are you how are you getting from one day
to the next I know faith in Christ what
has been the reaction from around the
world are you getting support
um what what's the temperature on this
thank you uh thank you brother Wayne yes
so as you said
um facing a maximum of five months in
prison uh and a fine of up to 5 000
Euros and
and the fact that even before the first
hearing the LGBT Lobby was already is
has been already at work to make this
law stricter because they're saying now
they found loopholes in it when it comes
to the word advertising because they're
making a difference between the
advertising clause and the promotion
clause and they already seem to know
that they're not gonna win this with
with me and the hosts because uh we're
gonna be like hang on
how can you claim we were advertising no
website was mentioned no phone numbers
were mentioned where's the advert so
they're actually angry that the law is
not as strong as they they thought it
out to be or maybe they planned it in
stages and this is a trial run a test
case to make to make the law stricter
because they couldn't start with that
massive impact they had to start yeah
slow so they kind of jumped the gun you
know they jumped the gun listening to
you on the radio which is totally you
know almost fit their involuntary except
for you weren't advertising and all of a
sudden you're called to the police
station and now it's worldwide news and
so you are really in the spotlight
that's true that's true yes So
eventually now the first hearing took
place and and the Witnesses are going to
be heard on on the 9th of June God
willing and everything like the first
hearing was quite short but now the next
one is expected to be much longer
because all the evidence uh is gonna
have to come forward
so are you there and the are the people
listed in the article that just came out
are they there and are you there in a
court environment
yeah so I don't know if you can see a
little bit of this here but basically it
says conversion therapy police report
against Matthew grack and journalist was
filed by top EU equality officials and
two others and the names of these people
are clearly mentioned yes on the article
so you on on June what is it June 3rd
now when you go it's the 9th of June uh
where all the witnesses will be heard
and the thing is you know we are very
confident in the legal arguments that
will defend us
um so I'm very grateful for the legal
team uh and
you know even if you know let's say
worst case scenario we lose this there's
still going to be an opportunity for us
to appeal it and to take it to the
Constitutional Court
as a constitutional case so it's uh it's
a fight and and even if we win it the
police can appeal it as well it's a
fight but I think from from us we're
determined to take it to the European
courts if necessary because we believe
that
um there are no grounds uh for us to be
taken advantage of in this way and at
the end of the day I do believe that
this was a clear plan to go to the next
stage of legislation here and this is
this case was just a vessel an
instrument that they needed to get to
the next stage of legislation which is
to start to come against churches and
prayer and deliverance and to creep into
our churches I know how these people
think of I have screenshots of
conversations with some of the people
who
um uh who reported me to the police they
are against the Bible they hate the
Bible they think it's an old book that
shouldn't apply to us they speak in a
very communist way so they are after
Christians thereafter churches and
they're not hiding this is clearly
demonic this is this is not trying to
um you know prevent people from being
forced this is not trying to help people
who are vulnerable that's not true
that's not they don't care they couldn't
give a flip about
um you know uh uh for people or people
who are suffering they have an agenda
and they want to reach it they want to
eradicate Christianity because Satan
wants to right that's right I'm I'm
really curious Matthew because we we've
talked a lot about about this
advertisement or promotion or whatever
they're wanting to redefine it as
what exactly was said
that was constituted in advertisement
because whatever whatever was said
caused this knee-jerk reaction to go
after somebody on the radio and now
we're now we're delving into freedom of
speech freedom of you know
the Press kind of thing so what exactly
was said that caused people to come
after this program
yes that's a good question and I would
say what did I say different because
I've I've done this so many times before
what is it about this one that took it
to the next level and um I I think it's
one of those times where
um I I felt the freedom to to uh mention
well I was not the the one to do it
first was the hosts who mentioned an
organization that I'm affiliated with uh
called The International Federation for
therapeutic and counseling Choice which
basically uh promotes a Biblical uh
point of view when it comes to sex and
marriage you know and and offers support
and help for people who identify as
xlgbt and and want to live faithful to
their values and uh and and they had
they clearly had a problem with it
because in the affidavit the name of
this organization is mentioned the fact
that it was mentioned by name so I think
this fact stands out
um when compared to previous interviews
that I've done so I think that was a a
triggering point
um
yeah and then of course it was you know
the sharing of my testimony
um and and that that they don't like our
testimonies uh being shared and promoted
in fact with the promotion Clause that
they're trying to include
our testimonies would have to be pulled
down from the internet which is
disturbing it is it is alarming it is
alarming we have to wake up to this
that's Marxist yeah that's very Marxist
so you can you can only be part of an
organization that they approve of and
like and you can't be a part of any
other organization that might have a
different system of values but if that
were the case we wouldn't even have
political systems in any country because
they're always at each other's throats
and always are on opposite sides of the
fence
so that's clearly illogical absolutely
so Matthew how does this affect Ministry
in your life today
now and how will it affect it if you go
into if you end up having to serve the
five months what will Ministry look like
on the other side
[Music]
yes
um you mean like if if
the if I had to be convicted and go to
prisons that we're saying yeah so now
you know do you do you believe that you
can talk about Jesus and exit from LGBT
culture today can you really talk about
that now and if if you do end up serving
time you know when you come out will you
still talk about being able to leave
LGBT culture for Christ I mean you you
have impressed me so far very much like
a Paul you know and I I don't see you
know you're joyful you're peaceful
you're calm you're not worried about the
future I know that you see that God is
going to see you through this
oh praise God thank you I I owe my joy
to the wisdom that comes from the
scriptures for sure and the the example
of men of God and women of God that have
gone before us right throughout history
but
um I would say
you know
we we have as Peter said you know we
have to obey God and not man and this is
one of those things where you know we
have god-given rights and there are laws
that actually are for us but we need to
know about them and and they're there to
protect us and and what happens is that
people make themselves Above the Law
because they have resources they have
friends in power and they think that
they can make themselves above the law
but we're here to say actually that are
there are laws that are protecting us
and you cannot
um do this to us and and use us as an
instrument to achieve your end goals so
um I will definitely continue and and
strive to be bold uh I think this is the
time where you know I'm expecting God to
do miraculous things and you know I
believe in Prophecy I do believe that
God spoke to me about this time that I'm
in
um he's spoken to me a lot about Gideon
and uh and just destroying demonic
altars and I believe that God wants to
destroy demonic altars and this this
battle that is Raging is because the
Gideon anointing is being raised up to
destroy these altars and Satan is
furious and trying to to bind Christians
right but but we serve the God who who's
with us in the fire uh you know we serve
the God who breaks the chains when we're
in prison he shakes the Earth
um he opens prison doors he's still the
same God doing that today and so we have
every reason to be encouraged and to
know that we're never victims because we
might be in Chains but the word of God
is Not chained up we can still praise
God everywhere we are we can still lift
up our intercession
um so there is so much hope for us and I
think the world needs to see
the real face of Christianity
um I think our testimony shines when in
the face of opposition we still refuse
to back down to to change something
about our worship I I think about Daniel
when when there were laws there that
were formed against him simply because
he didn't want to worship uh the image
of the king and and yet he still opened
his window in that upper room and and
worshiped God three times a day and
didn't didn't change anything about his
the way he worshiped worshiped God he he
refused to change his worship and I
think that speaks to us today you know
if I change the way I worship God to
accommodate uh these laws that are
demonic and and and and of course you
know ungodly then then Satan is winning
the game you know and that's not the
example that our brothers and sisters
need to be seeing right now so I think
it's time for us as sons of God to
manifest and yes even if I come come out
of uh jail I I will you know just as the
apostles were freed by the angel uh from
prison and they they went back to the
temple they were they kept preaching the
same message right they went house to
house proclaiming the Full Gospel of of
Christ
and so uh yeah I think it's it's it's
our time to shine and um you know going
back to prophecy I I do believe the Lord
has assured me of his protection
um of the fact that you know even I if I
go through the fire it will not burn me
it will not hurt me and that God is
going to deal with my enemies he's
spoken to that that to me prophetically
so many times and I didn't always
understand what he was referring to but
now that I'm in this season I'm
understanding wow God is roaring against
my enemies you know he doesn't see me as
his son and those who try to put us to
shame he is going to put to shame and um
I can tell you so many stories about you
know glimpses of the future that God has
given me to encourage me through this
season and the reason why I have this
hope is because I feel like the God who
knows the end from the beginning has
given me a picture of what is coming and
it's good and it's gonna glorify him and
the enemy is gonna lose and he's gonna
regret the fact that he tried to send us
to prison he's gonna regret it because
it's gonna work against him
so you have a strong excuse me you have
a strong local support system in place I
would imagine
I I think I think
um
I think God will surprise me with with
some people who will Who will speak up
for my rights to believe what I believe
I think When people's in Malta there
were so many people who got away with
corruption
And when they see somebody who's
speaking now the gospel and who you know
and who he left homosexuality to follow
Christ and you're sending him to jail
people are realizing like okay so now
it's like protecting corruption and and
sending Christians to jail what this is
not the malta that we know and this is
not the mortar that we we want you know
so I think people will start to arise
and realize what's going on and I think
there is a general tendency now where
the conservative movement across the
world is growing because people are fed
up with
too much of this nonsense
um at this point in our conversation
Matthew you uh we mentioned in the
previous program that people could send
a donation to you to support you at a an
email address that you were able to give
can you repeat that email address if
someone wants to send support for you
thank you dear brothers thank you
um absolutely so it's m a double t h e w
g r e c h at live.com
um and so yeah like uh we'd love to be a
blessing to our lawyers uh it's three
lawyers who are helping locally and also
being assisted uh by some foreign
lawyers as well from Christian concerns
so we'd love to be you know a blessing
to these folks and um and I trust that
the Lord will provide what we need to
you know get to the next hearing and
eventually if we choose to take it to
the Constitutional Court then you know
we'll we'll be ready to keep on fighting
this and and and facing whatever
expenses we need to face so that at the
end we'll see God's Victory and um his
name glorified because he's able to do
this so thank you for offering and for
your love and generosity sure absolutely
I'm reminded as you're talking of a
couple of things in scripture one as
you're talking about these experiences
and acts that you've been alluding to uh
there's the time where you know the
wisdom of Gamaliel prevails and and he
tells the Sanhedrin he's like look you
know there's lots of people that have
risen up and come and gone and he's like
but essentially if this is from God you
can't stop it and and in the Scriptures
it says in in Matthew chapter 10 26 it
says therefore do not fear them for
there is nothing covered that will not
be revealed and hidden that will not be
known and I see that happening a lot in
modern times you have lots of situations
in the world where for example maybe
people have been putting great wealth
offshores to avoid you know taxes or
legal implications and you know then
that's coming out in the public and how
people have been hiding these things and
you know different things or journalism
that's reporting on things that are
unknown and this situation what I find
particularly fascinating is I'm
listening to when the Trials come in and
at least in the United States June is
known as gay pride month gay pride month
and so I think that will bring even more
attention to the situation and an
opportunity for God to Prevail because
you know people will see the illogical
um situation at hand they'll see that
yeah I mean this is attacking people's
right to just believe something I didn't
think of that one that's a good one
yeah you've had a lot of exposure I'm
sure you're well aware In Articles and
in some uh YouTube interviews I would
encourage people to actually go and
watch the Beckett cook interview that
you did I really appreciated that and
I've seen some other YouTube interviews
that were good and I think that this is
going to be a great interview as well
because you get asked different
perspective questions from different
people you know here you have a couple
of people who have lived LGBT who are
still you know fascinated with this idea
that that to talk to somebody about
their desire to leave the LGBT world
could be criminalized that just makes no
common sense to us as Americans and yet
all the way around the world 31
countries now have criminalized the
right to be able to talk to someone or
even pray with someone who wants to
leave LGBT plus culture are you getting
support are you getting from from other
country I know Canada you you've gotten
some support are you hearing from from
like do you hear anything out of Asia or
Australia praise the Lord yes
um I have some friends from Taiwan who
have been very supportive from the
rainbow Crosser movement as they call
themselves
um so yes I'm very grateful for support
from our active Americans in this area
and yes you mentioned Canada a Hungary
has been supportive
um some friends from Italy of course the
United Kingdom very much supportive
um yeah so so friends from all over I am
I'm very grateful uh of course Eastern
Europe is normally supportive Lithuania
I must mention Lithuania that there's
the family movement in Lithuania which
has been a very vocal and has come to my
defense as well and even sent a letter
uh to um The Maltese president which was
very kind of them uh and and the hungry
citizen goal
um movement has also created a petition
and I believe sent it to the Maltese
president as well uh haven't heard
anything from the president no action
taken but
um hey you know their efforts have been
seen by God himself and uh and so yeah
very grateful that there is a United a
force against this evil spirit and it's
it's exciting
what would you request of us as to what
we can do for you
thank you so much I think I I Do cover
covet everyone's uh prayers so um I
think that's that's a major thing and I
think you you're already doing uh a lot
here you know you're you're allowing
this story to be uh to be shared with uh
the American audience and international
audience so um I think that's a huge
step so I thank you guys uh for for your
support and
um I I think you're you're certainly
playing your part today and I think um
that the Lord is able to touch uh lives
and hearts and um or just keep we just
have to keep pressing uh pressing in and
um and not backing down and not being
intimidated because actually we haven't
nothing to to be afraid of and nothing
to be ashamed of because the word of God
is is bringing hope right it's setting
people free from sin from from Death
from condemnation and so this is the
message of Life we'll never like bow our
heads in shame we God is the lifter of
our countenance and the lifter of our
heads and that's what we're gonna keep
on doing
yeah Matthew what's it like for you as
you navigate and circulate in Malta when
you're out and about are you do you feel
safe and comfortable or are you getting
people yelling things at you or or
people relatively peaceful about this
there is a a conservative party in Malta
that that um stood with me
um as well because there are uh two
conservative parties that are emerging
in Malta now Malta is a traditionally a
two-party system uh and that now that
both parties have become very liberal so
Malta was crying out for for the you
know Christians and godly people or
conservatives to be represented by
somebody because for many years it's
just been this liberal movement taking
um
you know prevalence so uh that's
happening
um I think in general uh you know I I
had for instance a popular uh singer in
Malta
um message me privately I think that the
thing is that people in Malta don't want
to show their faces that much but they
they privately observe and stand with me
but would not always show me or say that
because they they don't want to lose
alliances they don't want to lose
friends or colleagues
um but it was prophesied that in Malta
there would be people coming forward and
professing their Christianity and that
this will increase so uh you know I
think I think people you know we go from
one season to the next as we demonstrate
boldness I believe boldness is
infectious just as Sin and perversion is
infectious but boldness in righteousness
is Justice infections and it causes
those who are on this Sidelines or on
the fence to be like actually that
person is is like pushing my boldness
button I I feel like I've been a coward
actually I want to be more vocal I'm
stirred up now by this boldness you know
and that's what we owe to the lukewarm
Christians they need to see this working
because they will they will stand up and
imitate right so
that's good and your your family is
there in Malta your parents
they are uh actually no no my parents
live in Brussels
um my my extended family lives in in
Malta yes so my sister my brother and
and my grandparents and uncles and aunts
um but
uh I think you know now they they they
have accepted that this is something
that I feel very called to so there is
less
we don't speak about it now so so for
instance my family have removed me from
Facebook because they don't want to be
publicly associated with me at first it
was a bit like
ouch you know but then I understood you
know I want to understand their position
if they don't have Jesus like I do then
how are they gonna cope you know so
um I don't take it personally I love
them I pray for them but this is just
something that I had had to accept
um you know for this moment in time so I
understand it's not easy for them to uh
to handle uh they might not have the
wisdom to handle it but I'm fine with
that I have peace you know God has given
me a spiritual family and it's more real
than anything in my life
um so that's the the situation I thank
God that there is not
um much hostility or opposition there
it's just been calm now because my
family has has been understanding that
actually
I I'm I have to speak up about this it's
my personal journey and and I feel like
they silently respect me for it uh
although at times they might be confused
about what they should think and not
think about it honestly I feel uh there
are times they're confused there are
times where they silently respect what
I'm doing because they see that it's got
a good cause behind it
I'm guessing that you must be spending
some very concentrated time with God
throughout all of this
oh uh yes
um I I do have an intimate relationship
with the Lord I I spend time in the
words
um and in his presence and I worship him
uh also using my piano
um I encounter God in a special way when
I worship and adore him and um yeah I
pray for my needs I pray for other
people's needs
um and I I'm I'm not just a reader of
the Bible I'm a student of the word I
teach I've been teaching uh a course at
a Bible College here in Malta about
worship as well it's something that
happened this year which I was excited
about I designed the entire course and
so um yeah it's been a great journey to
dive deeper into the world of praise and
worship and how praise is a weapon of
warfare and uh I feel like God has
allowed it to happen now to also equip
me for what is to come so um yes thank
god
um it's the difference between life and
death the presence of God is absolutely
yeah
so Matthew there are I read in a news
article I don't know a year or so ago
there are 45 000 different denominations
around the world
um hard to believe but
um there's different nuances you know
within every denomination one thing that
when I began to explore outside of my
own denomination as it related to those
who have left the LGBT world is that we
are in agreement with what the Bible
teaches as it relates to same-sex
behaviors I don't find anything in the
word that condones uh an intimate sexual
relationship with two two people of the
same gender that that doesn't honor and
glorify God and so I've began to make
brothers and sisters all the way around
the world
who have been
convicted
of this that you give your life your
heart to Jesus Christ and your safety
and your identity is in Christ and not
in a sexual orientation and that makes
us one with Christ and so you are a role
model to me about when I come against
opposition and you know as you talk to
people from changed movement as you talk
to people from restored Hope Network and
and people from iftcc and and X Out Loud
you know that our lives today are met
full on with with opposition and yet you
are in uh you're on the firing line I
don't know of any other person around
the world who has been a benchmark case
for the conversion therapy laws that
that have you know happened all around
the world and so
um to to see this joy and this peace and
this forthrightness about Christ in you
is
overwhelming to me
thank you beloved brother I I thank you
for that I I think God has a
has a way of hiding Us in his Tabernacle
and um and I love that you asked me
about the presence of God because you
know if we dive into Psalm 91 we
understand you know if we we are hidden
under the shelter of his wings yes there
are so many promises
um that come with it you know and so I I
do know that the word of God is true
that God is not a liar and and
um that he hasn't changed one bit and
what he did was Daniel what he did was
Nehemiah with Esther with David with
Abraham with Moses with the people of
Judah and Jehovah jehoshaphat's time
um and so many other miraculous stories
that he's he's ready to do that and more
in our time if we would only
um
be submitted to him be close to him and
be lost in his gaze we just need one
gaze and look into his eyes and that
will just melt our hearts and every fear
every anxiety is just simply melts away
if you can just look into his eyes uh if
you were to encourage the uh viewership
with a promise that you stand on and I
know there's probably many but it was
what is one that maybe right now in this
time of all these things that you're
going through that you stand on on a
regular basis that's sustaining you
hmm
yeah I think
um well there are different of course
aspects for my life I think
when it comes to Holiness it's God is
able to keep you from falling and to
present you blameless foreign
with exceeding joy and I think it's this
God is able that stands out because
sometimes we're so self-conscious but we
need to be more God conscious and so
instead of I'm able it's God is able to
live in me and truly and so that has
kept me going and um and of course it's
it's also that God is God works all
things for the good of those who love
him and so it's about staying in his
love and obeying his word and it doesn't
mean that we we don't slip but
um God has a way of assuring us that
that we are living sacrifices even even
if we fail sometimes but the fact that
we get back up and that we we we present
ourselves before him again he loves that
he's not here to condemn us he loves it
when we keep coming back to him he's
like I see you as a Living Sacrifice
you're not defined by the that time when
you slipped I you're defined you know by
this staying power that you have because
you want to seek me and and and his
favorite sacrifice is a penitent
contrite heart every time we come to him
with a crushed heart sorrowful for sin
or whatever he loves it he accepts us
and he and he still sees us as a Living
Sacrifice so it's I think more about
keeping coming to him constantly not
being defied defined by times of failure
but but actually seeing the Fuller
picture that God is seeing he sees us
perfect and Redeemed by his blood and so
that's brought me a lot of comfort
yeah the Bible says that a righteous man
falls seven times but gets back up right
that's that's you know making the
distinction between the righteous and
the wicked and that's that's uh
beautiful thank you for sharing that
now I encourage everyone to watch all
the programming under LED light sorry
LED live and
um but if you're more interested in this
topic too you can also go to my YouTube
channel which is know his love
Ministries and there's a lot of good uh
programming under that of which this
will be saved too thank you first of all
thank you thank you to Matthew uh before
we close thank you for your time and and
please know that we will be praying for
you and we'll I'll definitely be staying
in touch with you soon love you guys and
thank you I will hold you in prayer as
well for all the fundraising that's
happening and for these uh programs that
are coming out
um in the near future thank you and very
good questions by the way I love the the
way you uh intervene at the right time
with very valid and important questions
so well done you were the Holy Spirit
was leading the conversation between you
four yeah I believe so yeah
we are blessed
well thank you all for watching this
episode of LED live and taking some time
to learn about conversion therapy how
it's affecting people like Matthew all
around the world and a glimpse of what
could affect multiple people around the
world in the future
so it's important that we speak about
these issues dialogue about these issues
and bring importance to them because
they have the potential to defect affect
every person on the planet so thank you
to Matthew thank you to Wayne and to
Daniel Daniel I knew that and I just
flew out of my head when I when I went
to Yuba and thank you guys for watching
don't forget you can donate to us at
littlelightstudios.tv or at patreon also
check out our shirts at lightwear.shop
and we thank you so much for watching
for supporting us make sure you share
this video like comment subscribe we
want to hear your thoughts and
importantly also pray for Matthew and we
will see you next time on the next
episode of LED live take care
thank you
[Music]
foreign
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
notice someone does someone need to go
out of your way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
[Music]
foreign